jour de rentrée pour le gouvernement
emmanuel macron a réuni ses plus proches
collaborateurs en conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui sans surprise la gestion de
la crise sanitaire et la vaccination
était au coeur des discussions tout
comme la situation en afghanistan les
précisions de notre reporter caccia
pique-niques
pas de grandes surprises et en effet les
principaux éléments avaient déjà été à
distiller ces derniers jours alors
gabriela talent le porte parole du
gouvernement s'est tout d'abord félicité
des évacuations en afghanistan rendant
hommage aux différents services qui les
permettent il y en aurait plusieurs
centaines par jour 2500 depuis mardi
dernier et 1400 avant la prise de
pouvoir des talibans mais par exemple
c'est moins qu'en que la grande-bretagne
au niveau des évacuations en revanche il
est resté plutôt vague n'a pas su
apporter de précisions sur le jour
limite de l'évacuation encore le nombre
de personnes restant à évacuer n'a pas
non plus répondu clairement à une
réponse à une question pardon sur les
interprètes de l'armée les interprètes
afghans de l'armée française qui depuis
des années déjà demandé des visas sans
pouvoir les obtenir alors le point le
plus complet portait bien sûr sur le co
vides il y à une stabilisation de
l'épidémie voir une lente décrue mais la
situation est toujours un peu
préoccupant puisqu'il ya encore
21500 contamination par jour avec une
hausse des hospitalisations et d
admission en soins critiques dans les
territoires d'outre-mer et bien la
situation dérape en polynésie également
gabriel attal a déclaré que c'était à
cause de la sous vaccination
donc en conséquence la rentrée scolaire
est reportée au 13 septembre en
guadeloupe en martinique mais aussi à
saint martin saint barthélémy dans
quelques zones de guyane en france en
revanche la rentrée se fera au niveau d'
alerte 2 en présentiel avec des
adaptations si la situation devait
s'aggraver
évidemment toujours pour le gouvernement
la priorité est de continuer à vacciner
les français
85% d'entre eux ont déjà reçu une
première
on écoute gabriela talent sur la
vaccination nous allons déployer une
campagne vaccinale massive aux abords
des collèges et des lycées aucun jeune
ne sera laissé sur le bord de la route
et la vaccination de tous est facilité
plusieurs options sont possibles selon
les établissements soient des
déplacements des élèves qui pourront
être organisés pour permettre la
vaccination soit des vaccins bus ou des
équipes mobiles de vaccination qui
pourront se rendre dans les collèges et
les lycées enfin l'autre enjeu de la
rentrée concerne le déploiement d'une
campagne de rappel vaccinal à
destination des personnes âgées et
fragiles l'objectif est clair il faut
maintenir les défenses immunitaires des
personnes les plus à risques qui
pourraient avoir baissé plusieurs mois
après la première dose parfois dès
janvier la haute autorité de santé vous
le savez a recommandé cette protection
pour les plus de 65 ans ainsi que pour
les personnes atteintes de comorbidité
six mois après leur première injection
nous allons donc la mettre en place et
le calendrier définitif précise sera
communiquée par le gouvernement dans les
prochains jours le porte parole du
gouvernement s'est aussi félicité de
l'embellie économique + 20% de
consommation en août 6 % de croissance
en 2021 et un taux de chômage redescendu
à 8%